oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what is
it you do Espionage congratulations on
this film and I'm wondering I'm going to
start with you Henry is the line do you
do the whirly bird do you consider that
the greatest line in cinematic history
because I think I do I think only time
will tell I mean we have have to let it
hit history first but um it was a fun
line yeah especially considering we all
we pulled it up
you know you both pulled off the whirly
bird in in practice well thanks I mean
in practice he really did well you both
you both did you both I'll go with that
well yes well you sir have been dancing
in films Tom Cruz has been running in
films since 1981 I think you've been
dancing in film since 1981 let's keep it
that way let's keep it that way I'm
wondering for you was this your
magnumopus in terms of dancing in film
because I feel like you've done a lot
we're going to keep pushing it and
pushing it pushing that envelope he'll
be dancing in space next
I want to see that can we create that
movie right now yeah so it's still a
work in progress for you a work in
progress okay but was that written was
did Matthew write sort of the dancing in
for you or we sort of found it along the
way we had an amazing dance team Ash and
Jenny who helped Henry and I there was
stuff that we did that actually didn't
end up in the movie tap dancing and
stuff I heard about that yeah yeah the
tap dance was was fun but really really
hard yeah it really sort of gives you
some respect for Gan Kelly and joke yeah
you'll have it in your future repertoire
for another film right um Matthew has
said that when he sort of talked to you
about this role he said a little bit of
bond with a little bit of Drago which is
my favorite villain of all time from
Rocky four nothing better he terrified
me actually as a child watching but was
that sort of the direction you got and
sort of how did you CFT craft Argy for
yourself um yes I mean that was as as
far as the sort of uh the physical
description of him goes but we sort of
discovered him along the way because
he's all the spy tropes turned up to 11
and he takes himself seriously but the
tone of the movie isn't taking him
seriously but sort of is and so it's
about treading that fine line between
the interactions he has with with some
characters like Ellie and then other
interactions with with John Cena's
character and you have to you have to
play
both uh recognizably similar but
different at the same time and so it was
sort of to find along the way but but
it's what you do and then the rest is
done in the editing process yeah cuz I
was going to ask because you played the
obviously sort of the fantasy
fictionalized version of a of a spy and
you play the real version of a spy how
do you sort of take the Spy like in your
head like if this is actor Studio
oneon-one how do you um do you play it
for real or do you tweak it I mean
speaking for Ary you can't play it too
naturalistically if you do then you're
missing the gag um so it was it was
trying to play it real enough so it's
not hammy but also keep it not too
honest yeah I I keep using the Broadcast
News as an analogy for the archetypes
that we play I mean or or Roger Mo and
you know in the train scene a a hippie
Indiana Jones but but like um you know
I'm Albert Brooks he's William hert you
know what I mean like I'm the the
journalist behind the scenes who's
sweating profusely and he's you know
beautiful and fantastic and so so that
to me is the juxtoposition between our
characters I was going to use that word
juxtoposition you stole it from me oh
well yeah you can't use it now I can't
use it now can't use it now you're just
copying him at this
stage I am no I heard something about
like a Harrison Ford or like yeah like a
Harrison Ford or like even a Han Solo
Yeah well yeah sure stealing from all
those archetypes you know uh I think
we're both taking from those you know
you have to respect the uh the stuff
that came before you so I know you mimic
each other in the sense like you Recon
each other's moves but then you really
make you each do the whirly bird but you
really made it your own so how would you
describe each of your whirly bird his
whirly bird is athletic I just I just
had good fortune of you dur leapa sort
of being the the pop star as she is
she's she's used to doing sort of insane
dance moves on stage and without her
sort of flexibility and her her trust in
me as well uh wouldn't have been
possible so did she just float and you
just put your hands there that's exactly
what happens that's kind of what I
figured yeah
levitate levitate and what was your take
on the whirly bird sir well we sort of
had got some help with some wires you
know we we did it both ways Bryce
carrying me and me carrying her and we
had also to do it with the fight and it
was very complicated that thing so it
was a little different it was a little
different but you do get dizzy either
way yes and I know you mimicked each
other's moves in the fight scene so
what's one thing you stole from Henry
and one thing you stole from well I
learned a lot from Henry Henry's done a
lot of fight stuff and uh just you know
just to pace yourself and not you know
get a little carried away you know you
kind of have it's a long it's a long
scene shut it over time and it's easy to
pull a
muscle how many days would you shoot
that over I forget I mean we we would
come back to it and do second unit we
was originally a week or two and then we
came would come back and pick up stuff
right yeah what did you take from Sam um
I mean it's impossible to take anything
from Sam because only Sam could do Sam
and so it's only sort of poor mem of
anything who are these people real life
spies why would they care about me
because you're a goddamn Fortune tiller
Ellie congratulations on such a fun and
dynamic film I have a question for you
Bryce I know that you know who the real
Ellie Conway is I know you're not going
to reveal who the real but is she going
to be revealed and is it a big reveal um
it's it is it it's yes and it presumes
that it's a woman too you're did I say
she yes I meant to say she but I I do
have a theory so I want to ask you who
is the real Ellie Conway wrong answers
only um I I mean I really just even
saying anything I think that you know I
I could just suddenly there could be a
dart that could come out of nowhere hit
me in the neck and I'm you know gone
which has happened before yes yes we
don't want to lose another one to this
question but um but yes there there will
the information will be coming out and I
know that because I keep begging for the
information when's the reveal gonna be
happening so oh my gosh adorable I love
it well I can't wait to hear um in this
film Ellie has a vivid imagination she
is a writer who gets dropped in the
world of Espionage so I'm wondering for
each of you if you or you got dropped
into one of your previous films and it
was a real life scenario which one do
you think would be the most fun to be
dropped into or one of your previous
projects and you can choose something
you directed as well and activ oh that's
fun um I mean I I I Lov Spider-Man and I
love that World um so you know I think
that would be a very fun world to kind
of be dropped into the Marvel the Marvel
Universe can I also be dropped into
Spider-Man too I think that would be fun
wouldn't that beun fun it's so fun hey
I'm thinking of a future collaboration
here now yeah spider Gwen and our new
villain why am I always a because you're
so good and the villain is what makes
the movie like a movie's success is
dependent upon the villain saying no
that's really actually I'm not just
saying it either because that was
actually my next question was asking you
because you are such a Craftsman of what
you do um sort of like the when you when
you are playing a villain there is a lot
of pressure right there's a lot of
pressure because the movie does have to
work um and a lot of it is based on the
hero but on the villains so what are
Brian Cron's rules for playing a villain
make him real yeah make his uh uh
choices and his uh agenda uh clear to to
me so that I can play it and if I think
if you if you play him evil or something
that that's an end result that's
something that you want the audience to
determine but not yourself so when I was
doing this or any character that is
questionable I always try to say what is
he really after and why why how can I
justify what he's trying to do she
represents in my world Ellie represented
chaos and things that are flying out of
control and I I want to get things in
order and and I'm trying to reason with
her to make sure that she can come over
to this side and uh and should be very
comfortable we'd make you very
comfortable did grew from Despicable Me
did I hear something about that
did being some some sort of an
inspiration or some not that you need
inspiration but being sort of a nod to
that you know it's it's funny you should
say that because someone mentioned that
early on and I thought you know there's
there's a there's a relationship there
where he doesn't see himself as a bad
guy you know and and that's fun to play
that way maybe maybe there is a future
in maybe Ritter my character can be
animated there you go yeah for you you
got to wear so many hats
playing this role um there's so much one
thing that you are known for is crying
on Q and you got to do it probably I
think I was trying to count like five or
six times in this film and I know you're
sick to death of talking about this but
was the taking off of the heels before
you ran was that your idea or was that
Matthews and is that a nod it's so this
is I'm going to give you such a boring
answer and I apologize but it is the
truth I'm I'm someone who's very like I
I I don't think of oh this fun kind of
Easter egg from this other movie that I
did to put it into this movie because
this movie is its own thing and treat it
as such and um and the
circumstances made sense you know you
always want a costume to to make sense
given whatever a character is doing and
um and yeah and so that was you know
that was just a like I knew there was
going to need to be a shift so that she
could go more stealth and um and so you
know you're going to lose your shoes if
you want to go more stealth and not be
heard and that works when you're not in
a jungle I love that you use the word
stealth that's perfect I'm going to say
one word and you tell me if it means
anything to you
fukes
Jason what was this shouted out on set a
lot and what was the sort of meaning
behind
it uh he's our uh writer terrific guy
very uh very talented Ed and a producer
on the film and a producer on the film
and um the as you might expect the the
the script is very dense and complex
it's not easily trackable because of the
mind of Matthew who wants to go to so
many different places that there were
often questions that the cast would have
at any given moment and and he would
scream out
F you know to bring Jason to the set
he'd come running to the Set uh to to
answer any questions sometimes the
fuches became it augmented to a curse
word in in some ways and in a fun
[Music]
way so I'm going to start with you sir
do a leipa and I'm going to quote her
has called you her emotional support
actor because the two films that she's
been in Barbie and this one you were
there alongside with her do you care to
respond to that and how do you feel
about her is she your emotional support
actress okay well uh I I don't take that
lightly um I I think I'm I'm incredibly
grateful someone would say that my my
takeaway from that is we we did spend a
lot of time on set and in Argyle it's a
it's very different than what I did in
Barbie in Barbie I was ridiculous I sang
to do Al Lipa horribly and I was wearing
a merman costume that was a different
scenario but that was actually the
second time we got to work together AR
guy was filmed years before that and
that was kind of her dipping her toe
into the Cinematic experience she was
admittedly nervous and was vulnerable
enough to share that with the group and
in movies you shoot a little bit then
you stop down for a little bit so we got
to shoot and we got to talk and she's a
a genuine real person we connected
through our lives as touring performers
and had much more uh deep conversation
than the normal just pleasantries that
sometimes you have on a movie set so
when I hear like this person is my
emotional support
actor that to me my takeaway is we
talked she listened and she had as she
had as much to take away from that
experience as I did so that's really
cool because you know everybody usually
gets along yeah but there's not a lot of
circumstances where you form a deep
connection with someone and uh if I
could help her perform she crushed in
this movie yeah she did and if if I was
a vehicle to help do that I'm grateful
but what most grateful for is that the
moments that I thought were genuine
weren't lost and that's that's important
well thank you for that heartfelt answer
and it reminds me of your tweets because
thank you for your tweets because
sometimes I wake up in the morning and
they give me inspiration and I'm like
damn he really has his finger on the
pulse of what we need to hear you came
off on the best dress thing I'm just
here to suck up that's all and by the
way I take mer very seriously okay
there's no joke there that was no joke
and actually it sort of feeds into what
I wanted to ask you because I know you
were cast in this before your Oscar
winning performance in Westside Story
and Matthew cast you because not as many
people knew you at the time so I'm
wondering for you if you can sort of
talk about that experience from where
you were then oh well I was
just honored that he even liked my tape
because I auditioned I put myself on
tape like if like you do you know and um
I took the meeting with him and he was
like so I hear you're in Westside Story
like I was like yeah but like I don't
think he really put together I was
playing Anita or anything which wasn't
really important to me because I just
wanted to know that I could actually
work that I had the ability to get
another job because that's the thing um
but we had a great time and he genuinely
listened to like anything I had to say
like I never felt small or anything like
he validated my take on things and I
really enjoyed that I think trust
between actor and director is really
important so I was just grateful that I
felt like I had done a good job I was
going to work with someone who was very
clearly a Visionary and he saw me I
thought that was just like
a a winning ticket you know so I'm happy
to be cry today my goodness I was not
expecting that but that was beautiful I
just saw ISS and that was a beautiful
performance as well so thank you yeah
you've had some projects since then and
in this film Ellie's character is a
writer and she writes about fantasy but
then she's actually dropped into that
world and see she has to see how she
does in that world so I'm wondering for
each of you if you as people got dropped
into the world of any of your previous
projects which one do you think would be
the most fascinating to see how you
navigate
it that's a good
question uh this one's not a bad one our
guys our guys not a bad one just because
there are so many layers I think every
everything or most all that I've done is
I don't want to say one dimensional but
what you see is what you get yeah Argy
has so many secrets so many twists and
so many layers that I think there would
be options to write Beautiful Stories
from this oh yeah yeah yeah I agree I
think i' Dro myself into this one I
don't know if I would last very long but
I would give it a go it's also not a not
a period piece you don't have to worry
about like life without air conditioning
or Internet
or clothes or anything good good point
um I know that you are a huge Kingsman
fan yes and you we've talked about your
wardrobe today you like a well-cut suit
like I know a John Cena suit when I see
one so I'm wondering if that was any
incentive for working and when you saw
the Hawaiian shirt that you were going
to wear you were were you like where's
my suit man no not at all uh it's no
secret there's a line in Kingsman that
says a gentleman is the modern day
Knight and a suit is his armor and that
resonates with me I this is what I feel
most comfortable in everybody's like man
you're overdressed I this is my uniform
this is the shorts and the t-shirt and
the ball cap and the wristbands I feel
comfortable in this this is where I feel
I'm my best self but I don't mind crazy
costumes as you saw in Barbie and some
of my other movies I've been wearing my
birthday suit so that's that's part of
the fun of creating a character so when
you're a you're able to step out of your
comfort zone especially on screen is
exceptional I wasn't asking Matthew
where my suit was because I know he's
got it for the next
one love love that answer and by the way
I wor the same thing on the plane that I
do to an award show that I do to this so
I you're I feel seen and heard um last
question for you um you sing a song
you're such a beautiful singer and you
sing a song that is on the soundtrack
for this Boy George yeah I know talk
about that amazing yeah he came on and
and wrote some additional lyrics to what
we had already come up with or rather
Matthew vau and Lauren Bal and um Stuart
price and Gary Barlo originally wrote
the tune that you hear in the movie Boy
George came on and was like I got a
little special sauce and so that's what
you hear in the credits and um now
Rogers as well adds to it and we just
had a blast we wanted to create a tune
that felt you know truly electric that
could you know provide this beautiful
underbelly to this incredible film and
it's a song that makes me dance yeah
dance you seen there's a video out there
of all of us doing it yeah yeah thank
and I heard it great tune man I just
went for it you really I'm sorry sorry
no never apologize do not apologize for
feeling joy and being encouraged move by
said Joy um but it's was great it was a
great experience and then also if you do
go to the film stay for electric energy
and there's one other tune right after
it called get up and start again which
is um that I also saying which feels
like the most epic end credits bondes
ballad that is very Argy for us so
between the two of them you will like
something I promise you it's time for
you to meet the real agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
God so I was actually just chatting with
Bryce and I said something to her she
asked if I like the film and I said it
is the girlier version of Kingsman and
she said well Matthew made the film for
his daughters in a sense or they were
inspired it so I wondered if you could
talk a little bit about that I mean the
fact that we have a Taylor Swift ask
catpack in the film jeal Lipa in the
film and then it was maybe inspired by
Romancing the stone that you watched
together during lockdown could you talk
about sort of your children's influence
in this and and how they sort of how it
switches it up from kingsman's it
actually it is meant to be the antidote
to kingsman so um antidote the antidote
so I don't know they you know when you
have you have a daughter yes I do and I
can tell you I think if you want to
learn well for me I think I've learned
more about being a woman for my girls
than anything and if I don't learn quick
they tell me off quick exactly yeah so
they're in charge um and they they
complained to me that they they
that um they just said that they didn't
ever F A movies made for them which they
could really relate they said was either
a dumb romcom or
it's I won't even say what they are
actually I get in trouble but you know
they so they asked they said come they
saw raning the stone and said please
make a movie like this for us so I was
like why not wow we did WOW Ser for you
I watched you in your and I won't even
call it a man cave because it was this
Lair that you have in this film um and I
read something about how you brought in
a desk specifically for Samuel and I'm
like I wonder how sort of the sets how
you catered it to yourself and how it
informed who you were and this gentleman
has said that you're you're undirect not
because you won't take Direction but
because because that's my favorite song
I sing that all the time when I'm on set
yeah do you really yeah just like
directable every way I love it I love it
but so so how did you if you were sort
of like a man on his own Island how did
you craft this
character he gives me a lot of leeway so
when he called me and uh spoke to me
about the character and said read it so
if you want to do it and maybe you'll
come play with us and I like okay great
and when I read it I said okay good I
like this and then I visited the set and
he asked me about the about the man cave
said how would you decorate this place
so we started talking about the sports
memorabilia that I wanted in there the
kind of people that I wanted to look at
when I'm thinking uh sitting around in
there how many screens are dedicated to
information how many screens are
dedicated to sporting events so all
these things played into that and uh and
you Tau me about American sport I didn't
know anything in the history remember I
like I like what yeah we started talking
about Negro League Baseball he didn't
understand didn't even know that what
could or would have existed so I was
like oh okay he allowed me to do that
and uh he allowed me to create the
character look because I essentially
look like this cuz I was here doing
something else and uh my makeup artist
Jake is a huge special effects person so
he just created that whole He sprinkled
glue and hair on my head and shaped it
and did stuff on my face and everywhere
he created it and it's it's it's
it's fun the fun aspect of doing this
job that when you find people that give
you the opportunity to create something
and bring it like he did even in
Kingsman when I showed up you know I
brought something that he didn't expect
and he accepted it no one
expected and the lisp your your double
appear probably get canel for doing now
huh no I get trouble for arue that you
overcame stuttering so yeah but that's a
whole another thing but um so he he just
toally allowed me to come in and create
this guy and use the words that he had
on the page to express who he was and
the words were perfect I love you went
big on this one too you went so big the
way we love to see you I have to ask
about the cat you're GNA ask a lot of
cat question you're like of course I but
you're almost like Ellie Conway away
because she couldn't go anywhere without
her cat she put him in the CAT pack and
I feel like it the same came true for
you because this was your family pet
that you had to bring on set so did you
feel like you and the cat were together
247 it was in I didn't feel I I was for
me it was The Nightmare of having a cat
not you know Ellie is a dream for me it
was a nightmare but I did fall in love
with the cat by the end but at the
beginning I I didn't think it through
and I said I'm going to borrow the cat
and became the cat Handler the cat
feeder cleaning cat litter I didn't even
know I don't know how you train a cat to
do it but they seem to know where to go
to BL um but it was it I love the cat
now I didn't at the beginning of the
film you didn't even though it was your
no they bought it without telling me it
was a big surprise com home one day we
have big German she we have a German
shepherd and I was like I don't know if
this is a good idea um but I I now do
love chip and I chip was a great actor
he was a good actor he was Chip did
great he did yeah very impressed last
question um who is Ellie Conway who's
the real Ellie Conway are you going to
reveal this at any time because I'm told
that it's a big reveal course there was
well well I don't know what a big reveal
is apart from the fact there is an Ellie
Conway the writer who wrote the book
everyone thought it those it wasn't real
and I said books don't write themselves
the book we just went straight in the
charts at number 14 which is sort of
phenomenal I probably have to thank
Taylor Swift for that even though she
didn't write it um and um yeah there
will be I don't know if it was a reveal
I mean we we were going to announce it
but it's become this big thing so we're
like all right well there is a there was
a plan we wanted the movie to come out
first and then talk about the book so
give it a couple of weeks and it will be
announced um ain't going to be like
Taylor Swift I think everyone's you know
like saying it was Elvis Presley it
wasn't well you could the cats could
have a play date though when you do the
reveal they could be there may I think
youd have to
ask
yeah